joining us here uh on the rich eisen
show is a former longtime executive in
major league baseball of the marlins
organization now in the media he is
david sampson here on the rich house
show how are you sir
good how are you i'm doing fine i don't
follow baseball anymore
after tuesday i stopped i stopped
following the sport so i don't blame you
why would you because why would you put
your any hopes on the yankees when you
knew exactly what was going to happen
well i had a sense that the yankees
would not make it to the world series i
did not think garrett cole would last
six outs
that i didn't see coming i'll be very
honest with you david why did you think
that this was a a result that would uh
that was uh
foretold the yankees have a great lineup
on paper but they can't score runs gary
cole has a great contract on paper he
makes a ton of money but at the end of
the day without foreign substances he's
far less effective he's not really an
ace
and so you're going up against the team
the red spots that are just better in
almost every way just with players too
many people have never heard of it's
sort of like the raids no one's heard of
those players but they're the best team
in the american league so
are you saying garrett cole is uh not
going to be the same pitcher because the
sticky stuff is no longer allowed is
that
truly what you are saying david sampson
i am saying that the new york yankees
are working very closely with the
commissioner's office and they are
trying to develop a foreign substance
that is agreed to by the union as part
of the new collective bargaining
agreement and they are testing that
substance by calling up garrett cole and
saying hey do you like this one do you
like that one
so that's what you're saying um what are
you hearing about the baseballs that
were used in the olympics that come out
of the box tacky enough that uh for
pitchers to to feel like the grip is
similar
to what was not illegal what do you
think
i think it's it's critical so when when
i'm running a team and i speak to my
players they don't want to get hit in
the head with the baseball they want the
pitchers to have a grip and if you look
at the weather
that happened with the red sox yankees
game um cole wasn't sweaty
and when you combine sweat and rosin
which you can use your rosin bag you're
going to get a better grip but co wasn't
able to do that because it wasn't very
hot and look what scherzer did last
night as an example he was schvitzing
from like the warm-ups
and so when cole's not doing that you
know he's going to have a problem and
any type of ball that they're going to
come up with is going to be to the
advantage of not just the pitchers but
also the hitters because hitters want to
be able to get in the box and dig in and
not worry about getting beamed by
someone with no commands throwing 98. so
uh short of bringing his personal uh
steam room to uh fenway park or any
place where he goes this is the new
normal for garrett cole and the yankees
ace that's on they're on the hook for
for
300 million steinbrenner dollars is what
you're saying david sampson
i was looking thank you for continuing
to repeat my name i like that you know
the twitter handle can talk about the
show nothing personal but i think what
we're trying to talk about is when you
sign a picture to a long-term deal the
way the yankees did you have to expect
better but you also know what you're
getting and what you're getting is the
possibility of greatness but the
probability of mediocrity and that is
not common to just the yankees it's
common to all of these free agent
signings where they just don't work matt
scherzer is the
exception not the rule where his
seven-year deal has been great but the
next team that signed scherzer if the
dodgers resign him and go against the
way andrew friedman is they're not gonna
get the old max scherzer they're just
gonna get an old mac scherzer
so what if the steinbrenner's called you
up like right now let's just say that
happened just wave a wand what would you
counsel them to do with this yankee team
roster etc manager what would you
counsel them to do
uh they're gonna have to get another
manager and they're gonna have to get
another general manager it's time to
make a change uh they've had a good run
brian castron's been amazing he's got
world series but he keeps trying to
build the team the same way and they
build a team to get to october they do
not build a team to get through october
and you want to take one year flyers on
corey kluber and allen and all these
guys i'm happy for you to do that but
that's sort of what we did with the
marlins when you're the yankees you want
to be better than that you don't want to
have to rely on what could be but what
likely won't be
you don't want to try to catch lightning
in the bottle you're the yankees
come on you've got to do better you need
more pitching and if cashman doesn't
want to go that direction and
steinbrenner doesn't want to go over the
luxury tax threshold then you guys are
never going to get another world series
former miami marlins president host of
the nothing personal podcast at davidp
sampson on twitter and instagram david
sampson here on the rich housing show
how was that was that reset to your
liking david it's you you have a good
producer that was really an outstanding
research you know david david
no no offense nothing personal but i did
that myself
um you know so
is that so you can save money by not
paying your people around you a lot so
you do all of your reads and you prepare
all of it i like that that's good
planning you know what there's an eye on
rich and eisen i do have a terrific team
around me and i will always give them
credit because that's the type of
professional i am but um i understand
that you want to give me the credit and
i'll take it i'll take it and run with
it so you you mentioned the yankees were
a team that was built to get to october
not through october which team is built
to get through october that is still
playing in this month
uh the tampa bay rays their team that
you may not be able to name 10 people on
their roster they're starting three
rookies in a row against the red sox and
it's possible they're going to sweep the
red sox i think they probably will sweep
the red flag you can get 460 plus 460
for them to sweep and that makes me
smile because they're a team that no one
wants to think is good but they have the
smartest front office in baseball and
they have no emotion
and that is what you need to be
successful in sports you can't listen to
the media you can't listen to fans you
have to have zero allegiance to anything
other than winning and to do that you
have to trade players a year too early
not a year too late and tampa does that
perfectly every single time i can't
stand the way they play david i'll be
honest with you i can't stand the four
outfielders in the shifting and the guy
sitting in right field who's usually
right around second base i can't stand
the openers
i can't stand it it's just not the way i
want to watch baseball i'll be honest
i'm a traditionalist i might be a
dinosaur at age 52 i might be a naysayer
but it just drives me nuts it's not
something i really really want to see
so the question is what's your goal
right so if you're running a team is
your goal to satisfy an aging
demographic who is just going to die out
at some point soon and by the way i'm
right there with you at 53 years old or
is your goal to get rings and somehow
get interest in younger people who want
more action like last night's game four
hours and 15 minutes great game i
watched every minute of it because
that's what i do but it's really hard to
get people to do that so what do you do
you have to do anything to make the game
more efficient and have more action so
therefore do we get rid of the shift do
we do everything that you're saying make
it so you can't do an opener make it so
you have to keep a pitcher in for three
batters by the way which they do and it
doesn't impact the pace of play at all
games were the longest they've ever been
this year so what changes can we make
and the answer is
i would say anything
including changing the batting order
letting people hit whenever they want to
in the ninth inning if you're down a run
let aaron judge hit three straight times
or stanton
anything because you the traditionalist
rich
you're a dying breed you know what david
um i don't appreciate that but i
appreciate it at the same time i'm
conflicted i'm not gonna lie
um so
when you say that though
i mean there has to still be some
semblance of an order for all of this to
work in my mind maybe again i'm i'm
wrong but how would you combat it like
because the the rays seem to have
taken an approach here where they see
where the rules are
and they're just
screwing with it
basically the way that i'm seeing they
just they they have taken totally
different approach with a slide rule and
a protractor and and allow the the
manager to figure out you know a little
bit of the gut and feel i guess do they
allow kevin cash to figure out the gut
and feel at all or no no there's no gut
there's no feel were you the guy back in
high school that you'd be all angry when
someone would get into a 95 on an exam
and not study where you had to study
really hard to get the 95 and that would
make you jealous even though they were
more efficient hmm
yes i was that guy david i was excited
so i i hear you and i appreciate that
and i used to be that guy and then i
went to therapy which i still do and i'm
working toward not being that guy
anymore because if i can get the 95 and
not do any work or out work or be
smarter than everyone around me and get
the desired result i want which is wins
rings and money not necessarily in that
order it means i'm doing something right
and you're doing something wrong
so
david sampson nothing personal podcast
cbs sports here on the rich eisen show
that's called a reset for radio purposes
david um so
what what would you do to build a team
to beat the ra which team is the best
equipped to beat the race then this year
out of all i think not until the world
series i think the brewers with their
rotation again with players you may not
know but the brewers have quite a
bullpen except for devin williams can
you imagine when i was president of the
team i had some players who got injured
with self-inflicted injuries right when
they lost their tempers or we would
always announce it differently to the
media we'd say oh they tripped on the
stairs or oh they were playing with
their kid yeah well we we'd make up
anything because we wouldn't want to
acknowledge the fact that they punched a
wall right or did something so stupid so
without devin williams the brewers may
have a small problem because huge their
setup guy but they've got a great back
end of the bullpen a great rotation and
a lineup that's good enough
and that could be good enough to beat
the rays but i think that's probably
going to be your world series as raised
brewers which is a real news fest for
people who don't like baseball so why
why won't the dodgers make it back did
the giants knock him out i mean the
dodgers were the team that actually went
through that analytics you know uh
heartless no gut no feel wall last year
when snell came out and jumped all over
um you know the result i mean they're
the ones who've got through it last year
why not this year
well the dodgers are financial bullies
and i'm i'm jealous of them because
they've got money they have money to
cover up mistakes that they make in
signings and in trades because if
someone stinks you just release them or
get rid of them and then the dodgers
actually can make trades we would trade
with the dodgers we'd give them our
overpaid players they'd be happy to take
them and we'd be happy to lower our
payroll but they'd want something in
return like prospects or international
bonus money or something to give them an
advantage so they really are bullies and
the reason why they're not going to get
past the giants is that the giants are
just a better team and they're having
career years from more players than the
dodgers have i've never seen anything
like what the giants did this year when
you've got six or seven guys having
career years at the same time it's like
my dream and in 18 years it only
happened for me once
so i guess uh uh one last one for you
here uh since you you're you believe uh
it'll be raised versus brewers uh in the
world series let's look over the
steering wheel here um with the the los
angeles angels sir with two of the most
generationally talented players to be on
the roster at the same time obviously
there's injuries and whatnot ohtani and
trout what in the world do they do they
got rendon as well
i mean ohtani's already made
you know a couple of uh ripples saying
he wants to win
i'm sitting here wondering if trout
would want off this ship if given a
chance what happens do you think david
with all that so i believe ohtani has
already agreed to an extension with the
angels i think when he signed with the
angels that he had been told that he'd
get to go two ways and that he would get
a long-term deal even though the
commissioner's office made it very clear
in memos to all of us that we could not
offer otani anything other than the
allowable money under the international
signing bonus pool so ohtani can say he
wants to win all players saying that
john carlos stanton said to me david i
just want to win i said how's 325 over
13. he said winning winning i'll take
the 325. so here's why trout is an angel
because he's in la not bad good weather
72 and sunny and oh my god he's getting
paid
400 million dollars
so ohtani can say he wants to win all he
wants but he will be an angel the
problem with the angels again they don't
have enough pitching when andrew heaney
is your opening day pitcher or counted
on to be at the top of your rotation uh
you got a problem and so the angels have
to be in the free agent market and they
have to get established pitching because
they are wasting trout's years and it is
so sad for major league baseball that he
has never won a playoff game in his
entire career terrible well david uh
just to wrap this up david sampson um i
don't believe you've been on the show
before you and i haven't spoken uh very
much before and i have heard your
material so i asked this uh question uh
not lightly at all are you out of f's to
give david sampson are you completely
like fresh out
of f's to give
david
oh i've got a plethora of f's i will
never stop doing an f about all this
stuff but what you're saying is do i
want to work in baseball again and the
problem is i did it for 18 years i won a
world series built the ballpark traded
players signed players sold the team to
jeter i don't i love what i'm doing now
in the media i love my show nothing
personal i love working with jerry i
love the whole package so i have no
interest in going back and the problem
with all the talking heads
on on on on tv is they really don't know
what they're talking about because
they've never done it so i've done it
and i'm willing to talk about it david
sampson uh look for my call one more
brockman
the mass hole here is really enjoying
this immensely
[Laughter]
david thanks for the call look for my
call again sir we'll chat throughout the
playoffs if you're available and up for
it thanks for the call i'm holding my
breath see ya there you go ladies and
gentlemen david sampson
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here